questions remain and president biden
plans to address the nation later today
to talk about the end of the u.s
military mission in afghanistan but the
state department is now leading the
effort to evacuate remaining americans
afghan allies and foreign nationals who
may still be trying to get out of
afghanistan weijia zhang is at the white
house with that part of the story wija
good morning to you
good morning tony and good morning to
everybody this complete withdrawal is a
campaign promise fulfilled for president
biden but tony you are right he faces
questions about leaving some americans
behind after he previously said that
troops would stay in afghanistan if
americans still wanted to get out now he
did say in a statement yesterday that he
would address his decision not to extend
the u.s military presence beyond today
secretary of state anthony blinken said
the number of americans who want to
evacuate is under 200 likely closer to
100 the administration has vowed to
bring them all home some republicans
though are sharply criticizing the exit
representative liz cheney said you don't
secure america by leaving americans
behind enemy lines betraying our allies
and empowering our enemies this isn't
ending a war it's losing one president
biden said the taliban has made
commitments on safe passage at the
airport and the world will hold them
accountable we will be listening for a
plan for how he plans to ensure that
when he delivers remarks this afternoon
because he has also repeatedly said he
does not trust the taliban gail
that seems to be the sentiment it sure
is hard to see the taliban walking
around with american weapons and
american equipment and american uniforms
that's tough to watch thank you very
much